Yeah,
no,
let's jump back to recursion.
So if I would like to compute multiple bounces,
I need to handle this somehow.
And we have talked about this briefly.
If I intersect the first object,
I need to reflect the rate off of this object in some way.
And after the shading is done,
if you specular MBN shading them,
we can trace the light further.
And this chasing step can be both reflection and refraction.
You remember finance law and snail slow.
We are going to put them in in use in a second.
But what I need to tell you is something's super weird,
but you won't feel why this is weird.
So either a tracer,
recursive ray tracer,
global illumination,
the indirect in relation and these goodies that we're going to start next sector
in the ray tracer.
If you encounter and mirror the ideal specular reflector,
you will balance the way back in the ideal reflection direction.
So we exactly what you would see in the mirror.
It's 35 degrees.
It is 45 degrees back and you do the same with diffuse surfaces as well.
So you continue the [inaudible] in Ideo deflection direction and now the sound
reasonably okay.
But when you were studying global illumination and how the whole thing is done,
how real men compute the rendering equation and images,
you will see that this is a super,
super huge simplification.
I remember the faces of students when they think back,
when they know all about global elimination of,
you're talking about simple reverse it for you,
Tracy.
And I asked them,
how is this reflected?
And there's silence because they,
you know that in wobbly elimination is going to be so natural that the DFU
surface means okay,
that it will reflect light in every direction with the very same probability.
So the perfect reflection direction has the same probability as coming back the
same direction.
Wait,
enter the surface.
They all have the same probability all directions,
and then suddenly a ray tracers faster.
Even a diffuse object I'm going to treat as in Europe.
So this is going to be super weird.
And please do remember when I say this later on,
if you take a look at Ray tracers after global elimination.
No.
How'd the recursion,
Brooke,
I hit something.
I reflect the road [inaudible] he chose her,
arose the perfect reflection direction and I moved to restart the whole process.
I'm going to start to trace a new rate that starts on the object.
Remember this is when you get the staff intersection tico zero.
I incremented this maps maximum depth value to show how many balances I have so
far and let's start again.
So I started to new way.
I imagined that this object is now the camera and this is whether literally
starting from
is there a question or,
okay,
so we got everything called does it look like in terms of mathematics,
the sister illumination equation without repercussion.
But now I need to add one more term.
Let's quickly recap this.
The first term is the ambient term.
This just to warm up the completely black shadows.
This is basically a bunch of hacks,
but that looks good.
So we are going to be okay with this for now.
Then we scaled the amount of incoming light with the material properties.
So diffuse and the specular shading model.
These are weighted by Katie and chaos.
This,
these are values that tell you how to use this
object.
And not only how of it is,
but what colors does it absorb?
What colors does it
reflect?
So what is the color of the object?
What is diffused and specular Obito of the object.
I'm using so many terms,
not because I'm inconsistent,
but because people use all of these terms and therefore you should be familiar
with this.
And there's some weird stuff that I now added and this is the recursion part.
So Katie is the front out transmission coefficient.
This is the probability of refraction because you remember that I hit this aired
last interface from different directions and if I hit them from different
directions than the probability of reflection and refraction is different.
So depending on the incoming direction,
you have seen this loser is stronger in one direction than the other.
And we have to account for this with this transmission coefficient.
And the it is the intensity that is coming from that direction.
The Kr and I are,
or the other way around.
So if there is reflection refraction that I'm very to go in that direction
and I'm going to scale this with the intensity of the incoming lights from the
reflection direction.
A quick example when if I have a glass that's blue,
so some kind of glass that that looks almost entirely blue,
done this for now transmission coefficient is going to describe the collar
that's bluish.
Therefore all the energy that comes through this ball is going to be colored to
blue
and the final reflection coefficient can be whatever.
So we are now interested in that transmission.
So this is how I can define materials like that.
This is the recursion part.
And for this I need to start perhaps multiple rates.
So if I hate this object and I say,
Hey,
but this is a transmissive object,
this is grass,
what do I do?
Because there is a probably the positive probably to usually for reflection or
refraction.
Do I start to recursions who I started two new race,
what do I do exactly?
And then the assignment about going to talk about,
uh,
you will see a piece of code that does something and then you will see the
effect of something.
I'm not going to spoil it.
And just a quick introduction to help personal [inaudible].
This is important because if you know this kind of notation,
then you will be able to discuss what kind of ray tracing algorithm can render
what kind of flight paths.
So as I started school,
all light paths go between light sources and the eye.
If it doesn't hit,
if it doesn't hit the lens of the camera,
it's not going to be recorded in the image.
So every light source is,
every light path is going to be written as owl,
something,
something II or as this is by reaction or you can imagine the other way around.
So you can see he something,
something else.
The denote was one diffuse into reflection during the way as is one specular
into reflection during the way.
And the asterisk means any amount of diffuse bouncers,
perhaps even zero.
So LD he means that either I hit that the eye from the light immediately or
there is one diffuse balance or maybe an arbitrary number of the few spouses.
This is what the asterisk tells you and we can also denote the choice.
The choice means that there is only one either specular or one diffuse spots and
with this smell,
that parcel notation,
we can discuss all the algorithms there are to render photorealistic quality
images.
So for now some of this will be intuitive,
some of this will be not so intuitive because we don't know global illumination
yet,
but first recasting means that we hit at most one diffuse object.
That's all it can render,
no recursion,
nothing.
I just hit one diffuse object.
I do the diffuse shading and Dubai radio city can compute something like
indirect illumination because multiple diffuse balances are possible.
So remember the example,
the light comes in to the classroom through the window wall and then you see
over and therefore the ombre is not going to be perfectly blunt.
This is called indirect in relation radio city Scott.
That covered recursive ray tracing.
What we are doing with this final transmission and reflection thing.
We know that what we can do is indirect illumination,
definitely not because we treat a diffuse object also as a mirror,
we just use a different shading function for it.
So we don't trace rays allow the hemisphere of the object because it collects
light from every direction.
This is why it doesn't change.
If I move my head,
this is why the sight of it doesn't change,
but we cannot account for that.
This would be a huge dimensional integration problem that we're going to solve
in the rendering equation.
So atmos one diffuse balance,
but you may have as many specular balances as far as you need.
So this is why,
because if ray tracers usually show you mirrors and glass balls and reflective
things like that because it is capable of rendering it that not so much more and
global illumination,
that's the full package and arbitrary number of diffused or specular dances.
This can also be glossy.
Whatever kind of complicated material model you have here.
This,
the ask can be anything.
And in any amount,
what,
let's take a look at an example with the Hagberg notation.
So here we have life paths and they start out from the light source.
So on the right I have something like LDD.
That's exactly what I have been talking about.
So I start from the lighthouse.
I hit a diffuse wall,
I hit the diffuse ground,
and then I hit the camera afterwards.
So that's led.
Let's take a look at for instance,
our S.
S.
E.
So I start from the light source.
I hit the glass ball from the outside,
this left glass ball,
and then I go inside the boulders stern to be reflection at least.
Let's imagine that there's going to be earth refraction.
And then I hit it on the other side as well and they come out.
So this is two specular balances,
l.
S.
E.
So we can denote flight paths and understand what are the rhythms can render
what exactly.
So here,
if we imagine that this is a ray tracer,
this is an image with the ray tracer.
The question is what did they do?
And this is a rather low quality image,
but let's,
it seems to me that the shadows are not completely black.
Therefore in their shading novels,
they definitely use the what kind of term?
Raise your hand if you know the answer.
Okay.
That's still not too many.
So normally this would be completely black because I showed a shadow read
towards the light source and it is going to be uprooted by the table.
So intensity zero,
imagine
that like all possible shadow race are blocked,
but this is still not completely black because I'm having a term to it in order
to work and make the image should be organizing.
So this would be which turn,
this would be the ambient.
Excellent.